CHRIS FISCHER: Well, it's
a pleasure to be here.
Thank you, Tanya,
for organizing this.
We just wanted to get together
and talk about modern New
England cuisine,
and where we think
it is, where we think it's
going, and drink some water.
We actually wanted to drink
beer, but they wouldn't let us.
[LAUGHTER]
Both these guys got the day off.
I don't really have a schedule.
So Matt Jennings on my right
was born and raised in Boston.
He had a restaurant
in Providence
for 11 years called
Farmstead, and he recently
came back to Boston to open
Townsman in downtown Boston
that three months ago
was just voted "Best
new restaurant in Boston."
Nico Monday, born and raised
in northern California.
He worked at Chez Panisse
for six years with his wife,
where he fell in love with her.
Everything I read
about you-- "They
fell in love at Chez Panisse."
Everything is so
beautiful at Chez Panisse.
So anyway, they moved
out here to Gloucester,
where Amelia is from,
to open first The Market
on Lobster Cove, one of the most
beautiful experiences of just
getting to that restaurant.
Jumping off the bridge--
NICO MONDAY: It's not
on the way to much.
CHRIS FISCHER: It's on
the way to the restaurant.
That's where you go.
NICO MONDAY: Exactly.
CHRIS FISCHER: And
then as he said,
it's literally falling
off into the water.
After The Market, he
decided to take his passion
for wood-burning ovens--
which we actually
all share-- to The Market, where
they serve pizzas and oysters.
NICO MONDAY: Short & Main.
CHRIS FISCHER: Sorry.
What did I call it?
NICO MONDAY: The Market.
Do you have a wood-burning
oven at Townsman?
MATT JENNINGS: No, I don't.
I wish I did.
CHRIS FISCHER:
You have a smoker.
MATT JENNINGS: I
have a big smoker.
Couldn't have wood with 250
residential units upstairs.
NICO MONDAY: Yeah.
That's a lot.
MATT JENNINGS: They
didn't want that.
CHRIS FISCHER: And to tell
you about myself for a moment,
I grew up on Martha's Vineyard.
I currently operate
my grandmother's farm.
She turned 100 three
weeks ago, two weeks ago.
Still feeding her very
well, and she's keeping
us all very well entertained.
I most recently ran a
restaurant in Martha's Vineyard
called The Beach Plum
Restaurant, where
I built a wood oven, and I
took it with me when I left.
NICO MONDAY: Good call.
You gotta pack 'em up when--
CHRIS FISCHER: That was
my severance package.
And I just published
a cookbook-- my first.
The Beetlebung Farm
Cookbook came out June 2nd.
It's on sale here today.
So I just wanted to get
together with these guys
and talk about seafood,
oysters, cooking, New England.
We served oysters today
from my friend Roy.
Roy is someone I admire
because he wears sweatpants
all the time.
And I mean, I just-- don't you
want to wear sweatpants pretty
much--
MATT JENNINGS: Leisure suit.
CHRIS FISCHER: Yeah.
Well, with an
apron, nobody really
knows what you have
underneath there.
But oysters are this
quintessential New England
food.
They're sort of--
they're so decadent,
and they're also so plentiful.
And so they're fun to get.
They're easy.
They're not very easy
to eat-- I mean, shuck--
but they're easy to eat.
NICO MONDAY: And
sustainable-- one
of the most sustainable
things that we have up here.
CHRIS FISCHER: And so we
wanted to serve oysters for you
guys to bribe you into coming.
And you guys both serve
oysters at your restaurant,
and so that's where
we're gonna start.
NICO MONDAY: There we go.
CHRIS FISCHER: What is
your first oyster memory?
MATT JENNINGS: Hmm.
Well, I don't really
have-- I don't recall
having a first oyster memory.
I mean, I have more of a first
clam memory than anything else.
CHRIS FISCHER: Which is?
MATT JENNINGS: Which is
going out and getting quahogs
with my dad.
CHRIS FISCHER: Did you
ever dig for razor clams?
MATT JENNINGS: Yeah.
Stepped on razor clams.
CHRIS FISCHER: Yes, exactly.
They're aptly named.
Do you have razor
clams up in Gloucester?
NICO MONDAY: We do.
Yeah, there's a
few left out there.
CHRIS FISCHER: Yeah.
They're very sensitive--
speaking of sustainability,
they're very sensitive to any
sort of changes in toxicity
of the water, et cetera.
So they are disappearing.
We were getting them from
the Island Creek guys.
MATT JENNINGS: Yeah,
Ipswich area still has some.
NICO MONDAY: Yeah.
This winter moved around
some of the clamming flats,
and there's actually a huge
clamming flat just developed
over the winter right
in front of The Market.
The guys have just been
out there going nuts.
MATT JENNINGS: We're
having such a hard time
getting any shellfish so
late into the season because
of the snow pack.
And ice was still covering
all the mud flats,
so they couldn't even clam.
CHRIS FISCHER: And then
when all the snow melted,
everything's broken.
Kind of like having a farm--
you wade and wade and wade.
And then you're like,
Oh my God, I'm thawed.
And then your--
MATT JENNINGS: It's
the big let down.
CHRIS FISCHER: It's true.
But Nico, you were
saying-- Nico, again,
came from northern California.
Your godmother is Alice
Waters-- probably grew up
sitting on the bar at Chez
Panisse eating oysters.
NICO MONDAY: I did.
Spoiled rotten.
CHRIS FISCHER: And
coming out, he also
said, "There's only one
way to eat an oyster.
Out of Alice Waters' hand."
NICO MONDAY: That's not
what I said at all, Chris.
No, we were talking
about whether you
like to cook oysters, or whether
you like to just eat them raw,
or different preparations.
And for me, it's one of
the most perfect foods that
comes with its own
spoon, and you just
do as little as possible to it,
especially when you're pulling
it right out of these waters.
Like, a little mignonette,
and that's all.
That's all you need, if that.
CHRIS FISCHER: What
do you drink with it?
NICO MONDAY: Well, we were
going to get a case of Tecates
and just go to town.
We drink a lot of rose up
at The Market Restaurant
out on the deck.
And that for me is also a really
wonderful childhood memory.
I don't know if that's
OK to say-- drinking
rose as a childhood memory.
But yeah, eating oysters,
and eating everything growing
up at Chez Panisse-- there
was usually a bottle of
rose close at hand.
And you're standing
up on the cooler
making pizzas
before you could see
into the thing, every
spare moment that we had.
You know, there was this place--
Tomales Bay Oyster Company--
to kind of answer your question
about your first oyster
memories, I don't remember
the first time I ate one,
but I remember going
up to Tomales Bay
and just sitting on the
funky old picnic tables,
and watching the guys pull
bags right out of the ocean.
And I just knew,
that is how that is
meant to be done right there.
Yeah.
I haven't changed my philosophy.
CHRIS FISCHER: I think it's
interesting on the Vineyard--
and that's what we
call where I'm from.
Or the Island, actually.
Because then you're not
referring to anywhere else.
If you're talking
about the Island,
you're not talking
about Nantucket.
MATT JENNINGS: I
know there's a big--
you want to make
sure that you're not
associated with Nantucket.
That's how Vineyarders are.
CHRIS FISCHER: Matt's spent
some time on Nantucket.
MATT JENNINGS: There's
Martha's Vineyard,
and there's everything else.
CHRIS FISCHER: Actually,
your first cooking job
was on Nantucket.
MATT JENNINGS: It was.
CHRIS FISCHER: At
a grocery store?
MATT JENNINGS: Well, no.
I was a stock boy first.
Like, I would fold
the papers on Sundays,
and put the sodas away.
The guy who owned that also
owned an adjacent cafe, so I'd
like leave work and
walk by the cafe,
and all the cooks were
getting ready for service.
And I was like,
ah, it's so cool.
Gotta get in there.
And they'd be like,
maybe next year.
And then finally a
couple years later,
I was peeling onions
and scrubbing dishes.
CHRIS FISCHER: Well, that's
the thing about growing up
on the Cape-- and we're
close enough here,
and Gloucester has
it too, but-- you're
surrounded by the most
incredible ingredients.
And there's less woods on
Nantucket than the vineyard.
There's a lot more deer,
basically, on the Island.
But I was just thinking
about my childhood,
going out in the wintertime.
And Nico came out
and visited me once
and was talking about
how everywhere you went,
somebody had a bucket
of clams in their garage
or in the back of their truck.
We actually went
oystering together
after a big rainstorm--
a huge rainstorm.
And the shellfish
warden came down.
And he wasn't mad that we
were getting the oysters.
The pond was actually
shut down, because when
you get a certain
amount of rain,
bacteria goes into the pond.
And he said, you know,
you can't keep those.
And we're like, all right.
We'll just dump them back.
And he's like, no, no, no, no.
Put them in the
back of my truck.
But growing up-- wintertime
especially-- my dad
kept a bucket of oysters,
a bucket of clams.
But during hunting season,
they were in the garage,
and in the garage,
he hung his deer.
So at night, he'd be like,
if you wanted clams--
and it's hard to
shuck a clam period,
and you've got little hands,
and you just don't quite
know how to do it yet--
so you'd go in the barn,
and you'd just be
like pinballing off
of these venison,
these deer hanging.
And then you'd have to
find the light switch,
and then you'd carry
the clams back in.
But when you start eating them
like that at such a young age,
just like at Chez Panisse, you
create a memory, a food memory,
and a vocabulary.
And your body
actually-- I mean, I
think that's such a formative
thing for me as a cook,
that idea of those simple, pure
flavors like a perfect oyster,
a perfect venison loin,
a perfect bluefish.
You're a big bluefish proponent.
And that's a fish that if
you're not on coastal England,
you can't-- I mean,
besides maybe smoked.
I mean, tell me a little
bit about your relationship
with bluefish, besides
when you give somebody
a knuckle sandwich and they--
MATT JENNINGS: Yeah, I know.
I wear one.
I wear one proudly.
I mean, it was all
kind of wrapped up
in the same experiences for
me-- bluefishing and surf
casting with my family,
and going out for clams,
and all that sort of stuff.
And so we'd go-- whether
it was the North Shore,
or way out on Smith
Point on Nantucket,
or kind of very remote,
desolate places,
that you bounce
through the dunes,
and take all the air
out of your tires,
and bounce the whole way
out, and set up camp,
and you'd be there for the day.
Great memories.
CHRIS FISCHER: Are there
bluefish on the West Coast?
NICO MONDAY: Not that
I've ever encountered.
CHRIS FISCHER: Do you serve
bluefish at the restaurant?
MATT JENNINGS: Yeah.
CHRIS FISCHER: Do people
order it when it's not a pate?
MATT JENNINGS: They're learning.
I mean, I feel like so
much of that is education.
Our obligation as cooks
is to kind of help
them understand why we
love, and why it's so great.
CHRIS FISCHER: And that's
part of the education
is just making it really well.
MATT JENNINGS: Yeah, yeah.
CHRIS FISCHER: You don't even
have to tell them what it is.
MATT JENNINGS: Well,
people have this idea
that it's like really fishy
and it's really fatty,
and oily and bloody and gross.
And I mean, there are
nuances of all those things,
right, in that fish.
But when done
properly, it's amazing.
My mom-- so I grew up with
like we'd go fishing and then
get back.
And we'd divide the
fish up, and it'd all
get broken down and
gutted and cleaned.
And some would go
in the freezer,
and some we would
smoke right away.
My mom would make
smoked bluefish pate.
Now I serve her bluefish
pate at to my restaurant--
CHRIS FISCHER: Her recipe--
MATT JENNINGS: Yeah.
CHRIS FISCHER: Amazing.
MATT JENNINGS: I do
it with weird shit
like kimchi and whatever.
Pickles, and stuff that
she would never do.
She'd put it on toast,
and that was it.
But it's there.
It's a part of me.
CHRIS FISCHER: And that's a
good part about your cooking,
about what is New England
cooking traditionally
versus contemporary.
You're taking-- Matt went to the
New England Culinary Institute.
Traveled extensively in America.
Cooked in Europe a little bit?
MATT JENNINGS: Yup.
CHRIS FISCHER: Whereabouts.
MATT JENNINGS: I spent some time
in Italy, and France as well.
CHRIS FISCHER: And taking--
traditional New England food
is simple.
It's meant to be cooked at home.
We were joking before,
the ingredients
are so good that-- we have
a long tradition of corn.
And Matt was referencing
the southern resurgence
of corn and corn recipes.
And this idea that they were
kind of the pioneers of it,
and we've had corn for a
lot longer than the settlers
came here.
And it's so good here that
the recipes were steam it.
MATT JENNINGS: Right.
CHRIS FISCHER: So
it's like four words.
Two words, actually.
Corn.
Steam it.
Salt.
MATT JENNINGS: We
did a lot with it.
I mean, we were talking
earlier about the grist mills.
Those are such an inherent
part of New England cuisine.
You go through these little
towns and rural areas
of Massachusetts, and all of a
sudden there's a mill, right?
And there's a mill there,
because they would grind grain
there.
Or I mean, they were
potentially doing other things--
making paper, whatever--
but those communities
were begun by having the
necessity to create food.
CHRIS FISCHER: And I
think too with real estate
being-- in New England,
the land is really fertile,
but there's not huge
expenses like the Midwest.
And corn is a lot more efficient
to grow than other grains,
and so that makes
a lot of sense too.
The same with the best lobster
I've known-- the best bluefish,
all those ingredients
are so simple.
Or just the simple shucked clam.
MATT JENNINGS: I think our
settlers learned early on
that New England
both climate and soil
weren't the best
for corn, either.
It's kind of hard to grow
corn on the mountain.
And a lot of that is rocky soil.
CHRIS FISCHER: And
Nico is a transplant,
as we say, with a
wife who grew up here.
And you learned to
cook-- and you, again,
go back to northern California.
And I ate at Matt's
restaurant yesterday.
There's Little Gems on the menu.
You can't be a cook
and not be influenced
by what is happening out there.
And so now that you've
been here for five years--
NICO MONDAY: Yep.
This is number six.
CHRIS FISCHER: Number six.
Are you a California cook
who's cooking in New England,
or are you a New England cook?
NICO MONDAY: I knew you
were going to ask that.
CHRIS FISCHER: That's
because I sent you
that question in advance.
NICO MONDAY: I don't think
that they're necessarily
mutually exclusive.
You know, what does that
mean, to be a California
chef or a New England chef?
Like right now, I
live in New England,
and I live up in Gloucester, and
I make my home there, and use
all of the ingredients that
Gloucester and the North Shore
have to offer.
So I think in that sense, I'm
very much like a New England
chef at this point.
CHRIS FISCHER: And eating
at your restaurant,
The Market-- I was saying that
it has that French influence.
It has that northern
Californian influence.
And you were saying you spent
time in France, before you even
knew what the heck you were
doing, at 19 years old.
And I mean, growing up, your
parents worked at Chez Panisse?
MATT JENNINGS: They did, yeah.
They met there.
Like Amelia and I.
CHRIS FISCHER: That's
cooking school right there.
You went to cooking school.
You had a very
different experience.
I tried to go to cooking school.
I dropped out.
Before that, I washed dishes.
I cooked, but then
you didn't get
fed as well as the dishwasher.
And I was really hungry, so
I started washing dishes.
And then I just jumped
into restaurants
after doing all
the wrong things.
Do you feel-- they're
very different journeys,
but what's your feeling
on culinary school?
Like if a kid drops
out of high school,
or from graduates
from high school
and doesn't know
what he wants to do,
would you tell them to
go to culinary school?
MATT JENNINGS: It's hard.
I mean, we have that
conversation internally a lot.
I mean, we get as many great
cook out of culinary school
as we do get shitty ones.
I mean, it's all a matter
of what you put into it
and if you really
want to be doing it.
I think the kids that-- I
shouldn't call them kids
because they're not all kids--
I think the students who
go through culinary
programs either-- it's
like any other career.
You're either going to blossom
and find out that that's really
what you want to do,
and then every day
is a joy, to a
degree, or you're just
doing it because you don't
know what else you want to.
But for me it was great,
because I didn't make it
through regular college.
I made it through one
year and that was it.
That was all I could handle.
That's all administration
could handle.
They said, get this
kid out of here.
And so I took a year off.
And I went back to
this place that I
had grown up working, in the
grocery and in the restaurant.
And I said to myself,
what do I know how to do?
I know how to cook.
I love to cook.
So why don't I look into that?
So for me, it made
the most sense.
It was the next progression.
And where I went to
school was perfect for me.
NICO MONDAY: Don't
you feel like, though,
that whether you go to
a cooking school or not,
that you end up starting in
the same place in a restaurant?
And so long as you end up
in the right environment,
with the right
eagerness-- whether you've
gone through a program
or not-- you're
going to start at
that same spot.
Not that you don't
learn skills--
practical ones-- there,
but cooking school,
it always seemed
to me, was like you
were going to get
the real experience,
hands on, whether you knew
what you were doing or not.
MATT JENNINGS: Yeah.
I think, though, that's the
liberal decision like that I
couldn't make at that
time, because I needed
the safety of the least knowing
that if this thing-- like,
I didn't know where
to go as a cook.
to go work, or who
I should look to as a
mentor, or any of that stuff.
Or if I even knew
that I was really
going to want to do this
80, 90 hours a week.
So I needed that
ability to figure out.
CHRIS FISCHER: I
think no matter what,
most successful
chefs that I know
got a foundation somewhere.
So you got a foundation
in cooking school.
You had those skills.
I got a foundation under
Mario Batali at Babbo,
and that was like my
most focused time--
two and a half years solid.
You had a foundation, which
sounds like France, then
six years of Chez Panisse
before opening your own place.
And that's the biggest thing.
If you have the
foundation, then there's
the question of is it
better to stay in one place,
or jump around and
take these influences?
And I also was
lucky enough to cook
under the umbrella of Alice
Waters' world and Fergus
Henderson's world--
and I see a lot
of Fergus' influence
in your love for pork--
and Keith McNally and Mario.
And I was very lucky to
cook for these great people.
And you steal a little
something from each one.
And I think the bottom
line with all of them
is give somebody a glass
of wine as soon as they
walk in your restaurant.
NICO MONDAY: That's
what we've learned.
CHRIS FISCHER: Yeah, right?
MATT JENNINGS: We wouldn't
be there without them, right?
Give them what they want.
CHRIS FISCHER: So yeah.
I mean, we've all jumped
around a little bit.
And now looking
at the influence--
and I'm going to use you as an
example of being in Providence,
being a New England guy,
and coming back to Boston
and getting a lot
of attention for
a big, exciting new restaurant--
you're taking traditional New
England flavors, you're
taking traditional New England
ingredients, and adding so
many different-- I wrote down.
I probably can't find it right
now-- some of the ingredients
that you're using.
From andouille sausage-- am
I pronouncing that right?
MATT JENNINGS: Yup.
CHRIS FISCHER: Which is actually
a raw, extraordinarily spicy
pork sausage, and blood
oranges, and coconut milk.
shiso leaves.
MATT JENNINGS: Middle
Eastern influences.
CHRIS FISCHER: And I
was trying to classify
some of your influences,
but then it's
just a global cuisine.
And we live in a global world,
thanks to people like Google
and the rest of-- Anthony
Bourdain, and media,
and all of that.
And so here you are, a
young influential chef
doing a New England brasserie.
And it's exciting, because
there kind of aren't
any rules in certain ways.
I mean, do you feel
that way, or do you
feel like you have to appease?
MATT JENNINGS:
Well, I mean, think
I just kind of have reached
a point in my career
where I really don't care.
I think I spent a lot of
time in my early 20s--
so I opened my first
business when I was 25.
And it started off as retail.
It was an artisan food
showcase of sorts-- you know,
charcuterie, cheeses,
olive oils, pastas.
And then we opened
the restaurant
a couple years later,
which was right next door.
So I could run back and
forth and like, if somebody
was in the shop and staring
at something on the shelf
and was like, the hell do
I do with salted capers?
I had the ability
to go in there,
grab something, be
very improvisational.
But I think I was always
really kind of conscious
of wanting stuff to be
a certain type of food--
very well designed and
integrated into the greater
ethos of the
restaurant and shop.
And now, I mean,
I think I just--
it's not to say that it's not
as thoughtful, but I feel like--
CHRIS FISCHER: It's
more thoughtful
because you have
more references.
MATT JENNINGS: Yeah, I think
I'm able to just kind of cook
the way that I want to cook,
and not worry about what people
think about it.
And typically I think
that's when it actually
gets really good.
CHRIS FISCHER: And that's when
more people start thinking
about what you're doing.
What about you?
NICO MONDAY: Well,
I mean, I think
what you're getting at is like
you cook what you want to eat.
At least, for us with a
daily changing menu that's
very small, you know,
it's hard to appeal
to a mass number of
people on a daily basis,
whereas you just come
up with a simple formula
that you know you're
going to kind of like
cover some bases for people.
But at the same time, we
wake up in the morning,
and I'm sure like you,
you talk to your fish guy,
and you say, hey.
What's looking good today?
You look at what is coming
in from the farms that day,
and you say OK.
What do we want to
have for dinner?
CHRIS FISCHER: It's
freedom between cooking
with local ingredients and
cooking a local cuisine,
especially when a local
cuisine is not traditionally
a restaurant cuisine.
And you're again, bringing
that California influence
and that simplicity and that--
NICO MONDAY: Well, but I think
that's the philosophy of it,
but that's what we're
all talking about
anyway is just an
ingredient-driven style
of cooking.
You could call that
Californian, you
could call that New
England, because all we're
talking about now is like, OK,
what is the bounty out here?
It's the bounty of the ocean
and these beautiful farms
that are at least in season for
parts of the year this year.
CHRIS FISCHER: Well, that's
the thing about everyone
that spends time in California
for a certain amount of time.
You come back to New England
and it's like, oh my God.
Thank you for the seasons again.
But the reality too
is that the seasons
are so micro-- four
seasons are too broad.
In the book, we
did six sections,
which is a little bit
bigger than four seasons.
And then we broke that down
into 17 different menus,
with the idea that week
to week, day to day,
there is such a
change of ingredients,
and a change in the
same ingredients
from like the very first
strawberries that are just
like a little tart, and you're
like so excited to eat them.
But they're not that good,
and they get perfect--
MATT JENNINGS: And
then they're gone.
CHRIS FISCHER: And
then they're overripe
and you're still trying to
coax some love out of them,
but they look like crap.
But they still taste good.
MATT JENNINGS: I
think that's kind
of why I love being from
here and cooking here.
I feel like it's
more rewarding--
because I lived in California
as well for a while--
I think it's more
rewarding for me
to cook here that it is in
a part of the country that
has amazing produce
and accessibility
to incredible ingredients,
because our season's shorter
here.
So when it comes, it's
like this crazy love affair
that you have for
like three months,
and it's just [SLAMS FIST].
When snap peas first come,
it's like they're everywhere.
They're all over the menu.
CHRIS FISCHER: Or like
three weeks, or three days.
MATT JENNINGS: Yeah, or
however long you can get them.
You're pickling them.
You're putting
them in your pasta.
You're doing all sorts of
stuff, and then they're gone.
And then it's on
to the next thing.
For me, I just love that.
My favorite time of year is
like September, October, when
we're getting tomatoes,
but we're also
starting to see squash.
And you're in that shoulder
season, and you're like,
oh yes.
I have the bounty of
everything at this time.
You can put pumpkin and
tomato on the same dish,
and people are like, what?
CHRIS FISCHER: Radishes and
beets and green tomatoes.
MATT JENNINGS: Yeah.
It's amazing.
CHRIS FISCHER: I'm trying
to think-- what ingredient
is out right now that you're
so excited about that's
going to go away really soon?
MATT JENNINGS:
Berries right now.
CHRIS FISCHER:
Berries-- strawberries?
MATT JENNINGS: And blueberries
are just starting right now.
NICO MONDAY: Yeah.
And the very beginning
of like raspberries
and black raspberries.
CHRIS FISCHER: Are you
seeing those already?
NICO MONDAY: Yeah.
We've got them in our backyard.
CHRIS FISCHER: Wow.
I'm thinking of peas.
We are at the end
of the pea season,
and they're starting
to get woody.
And chervil is on its way out.
Are there fava beans?
Are you getting fava beans?
That's a very
California ingredient.
And you had favas
on your menu too.
MATT JENNINGS: Yeah,
the end of them.
NICO MONDAY: That's so
funny, because all the farms
we work with, the favas
are on the way out.
And then again in my
backyard, we just--
I'm obviously not a farmer--
so we got a little late start.
CHRIS FISCHER:
What's the skin tone?
NICO MONDAY: A little
late start in the season,
because we've still got favas
like that big in my backyard.
MATT JENNINGS: Well,
so I love favas,
and they're always
here and then gone.
So last year, we actually tried
some new preservation methods,
so we're actually
living off right now
some favas that we got in right
in the beginning of the season.
so people are going to
cringe when I say this,
but we actually froze a bunch.
CHRIS FISCHER: I was
going to say that,
because they get farty
if you don't, right?
MATT JENNINGS: Well,
they're awesome, though.
We actually steam them, and
then we flash froze them,
and they're incredible.
They're incredible.
I pull them out, they're
like just shucked.
CHRIS FISCHER: That's
a perfect example
of modern-day technology.
You are a chowder guy?
Everybody-- I mean, you
can't not like-- I mean,
it's New England.
NICO MONDAY: Well, that's
what we were talking about.
Corn and lobster
chowder-- when that
comes in next month,
that's going to be--
or whenever corn's going
to start popping up.
CHRIS FISCHER: Do you
make seasonal changes
to your chowder?
MATT JENNINGS: Yeah.
And you mentioned
the corn thing.
It's really funny, because
my wife brought corn home
for the first time from the
supermarket the other day.
And whatever-- you buy
vegetables the kids want.
You know, we've got to feed our
children, and they love corn,
and it's finally here.
But like I ate it, and
I was just like, ah man.
NICO MONDAY: It's
not quite there.
MATT JENNINGS: I said,
why'd you buy corn?
CHRIS FISCHER: She's
like, I wanted.
MATT JENNINGS: She's
like, the kids like corn.
It's in season.
I'm like, it's
not really in now.
Not here, not here, it's not.
Not really.
September-- let's talk
about corn in September.
CHRIS FISCHER: And
again, the thing
about seasonal cooking
too-- the problem
that I have with the way
people talk about those choices
is that they sort of make
moral judgments about you.
And that's not the point.
There's two reasons
to buy seasonally.
It's that you're going to give
a farmer-- ideally-- your money,
and they're going to
then take that money,
and hopefully they're going
to send their kids college.
MATT JENNINGS: Reinvest
it in the community.
CHRIS FISCHER: Or they're going
to be able to grow more food,
and your food is going
to be that much better.
NICO MONDAY: Invest it in
their farm, most likely.
CHRIS FISCHER: Hopefully
fix their tractor.
My tractor's been
broken for three weeks.
I can't get anybody to fix it.
It's so annoying borrowing
people's tractors.
My grandfather-- he famously
had cleared like 125 acres
with a bucket-less tractor.
No headlights.
Finally, his boss
bought him a tractor.
He was so excited.
And he would eat
dinner with the family,
and then he would go out and
the tractor had headlights,
so he would work all night.
And he was so pumped.
And then he ran it into a tree
and shattered the whole thing.
And he's like, all right.
I'm done with that.
But the other night, I found
myself-- I borrowed a tractor.
My tractor's been
broken for so long--
I borrowed my friend's tractor.
It was raining.
It was Saturday night.
The sun is coming down,
and I'm like scooping
this last bit of compost
to put in the fields.
And I was not even close to
done, and I had that moment.
That's where maybe you gain
some wisdom from your elders.
I was like, all right.
I'm turning it off.
And I went to bed.
And I didn't work at night.
But I've definitely ridden
some of my fields at night.
For me, I want to
write about food.
I want to cook food.
I want to grow food.
There's not enough hours
in the day for any of that,
and so you have to pick
and choose your battles.
And last year running the
restaurant, writing the book,
and cooking was very
fruitful in many ways.
NICO MONDAY: Do you
think that you'll
go back to professional
cooking at some point?
CHRIS FISCHER: Yes, definitely.
Certainly.
And I spent the winter in
Japan actually doing some work,
helping to open some
restaurants there.
And the correlation
between the ingredients
and especially my last few
weeks there on an island
in Japan-- simple, simple.
It's the only place that I love
eating oysters for breakfast.
That's like the best
thing in the world.
Oysters, clams,
any pure protein.
And it's like I
stayed on this island.
For breakfast, it was rice,
raw fish, and a poached egg,
and some seaweed.
That's the thing about--
and I referenced it
before-- my grandmother
just turned 100 years old.
And when you work on a farm,
and you're outside all day,
and you're growing the food, and
you're taking care of the soil,
your food is that
much more nutritious.
You're getting the
exercise you need.
You don't have to go to a gym.
You're not stuck indoors,
and it's so good for you.
That's the third part of
eating seasonally, especially
seasonally and locally.
And again, there's many
reasons for eating locally,
but if you're living
in an area, and you're
eating your local honey,
your allergies are less.
NICO MONDAY: The reasons are--
CHRIS FISCHER: The
reasons are infinite.
NICO MONDAY: Yes.
CHRIS FISCHER: So I think being
a modern-day New England cook,
chef-- whatever you are,
however you want to influence,
however you want
to feed yourself
or your family-- I guess
we all agree that there
aren't that many rules.
And hopefully
restaurants are going
to have some influence
in that conversation.
Hopefully the literature
that's coming out,
and the books from
the area-- there's
a lot of exciting New
England cookbooks--
and just keep supporting farms.
NICO MONDAY: Yeah.
I mean, I feel like we-- I
know there have always been--
and it sounds like
especially your rich heritage
on Martha's Vineyard-- there
has always been a rich farming.
But I feel like on
the North Shore,
where we were opening
five, six years ago, there
was just more and more really
young entrepreneurial farmers
just coming out of the
woodwork every day.
And it's been really fun
to kind of watch that
grow along with the restaurant.
CHRIS FISCHER: Well,
that's the nice thing
too for you growing up
in northern California,
growing up in Alice Waters'
world-- those chefs were
the first celebrity chefs.
And they celebrated
Bob Cannard, and then
Bob Cannard-- he's a
farmer there-- then
he starts celebrating
the farmers,
and I feel like
that's where we're at.
And so that's a
great progression.
MATT JENNINGS: One
thing that's hard--
because you have the land
expense is so much greater--
CHRIS FISCHER: And
farmers are pretty grumpy.
MATT JENNINGS: Yeah, yeah.
CHRIS FISCHER: For good reason.
MATT JENNINGS: For good reason.
CHRIS FISCHER: No, it's true.
MATT JENNINGS: But it's very
hard to find affordable land,
right?
So now thankfully there's
all these new land
leasing programs, and--
CHRIS FISCHER: The Land Trust.
MATT JENNINGS: Land
Trust for them.
But it's challenging
for people you
aren't fortunate to
have grown up on a farm,
or have family provenance.
It makes a really
challenging career.
CHRIS FISCHER: It's
challenging for every reason.
MATT JENNINGS: I mean, in
general, yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
But then it's just
compounded by all that.
CHRIS FISCHER: All right.
Well, does anybody
have any questions?
I can't see you, but.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
CHRIS FISCHER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So you talked about
getting your ingredients based
on the seasons, and so forth.
What do you do when
there's seven feet of snow
for three months at a time?
NICO MONDAY: I'm really glad
that we're talking about that.
CHRIS FISCHER: I'll just
repeat the question in case--
it's what do you do
in the wintertime
when you're a
seasonally-driven restaurant
or seasonally-driven
human being?
There's many ways
to preserve food.
A lot of them are
labor-intensive.
There's freezing.
I know an old farmer--
Ralph Sherman.
He lives down the road from me.
He grows beautiful,
beautiful food,
and he's about 85 years old--
and when the corn comes in,
he'll grow as much as he
can, take it off the cob,
blanch it, cryovac it.
It goes in the freezer.
He'll eat some of it fresh, but
then he keeps storing it up.
That's a very
labor-intensive way to do it.
NICO MONDAY: I mean, I know for
us-- The Market Restaurant's
a seasonal restaurant.
So five years ago
when we opened that,
we never had to deal with that.
And two years ago when we opened
our year-round restaurant,
we had to make really
conscious decisions about that.
And where we ended
up was the concept
that we thought would allow
us to still kind of stay
true to the ethos of really
doing ingredient-driven stuff.
And so it's a big raw bar
and a wood-fired pizza oven.
And the seafood
and the shellfish--
if anything it just gets better,
provided it's not an iceberg
field and people can get at it.
CHRIS FISCHER: You can eat
vegetables in New England up
until Thanksgiving easily.
December you can
still find them.
NICO MONDAY: Well,
and then we were
talking about root cellars.
We lived off of one of
our farm's root cellars
for the rest of the winter.
And we put up stuff-- one whole
wall of the restaurant's just
that beautiful--
MATT JENNINGS:
Pickles, preserves.
NICO MONDAY: In September,
when all the farmers are
unloading those last 400, 500
pounds of tomatoes on you.
MATT JENNINGS:
I'll take them all.
NICO MONDAY: I'll take them all.
CHRIS FISCHER: The
other thing that's
nice too is if you really are
going to stick to your guns
in January and February
and you're not completely
depressed from all the snow
is like eat a lot of protein,
and eat a lot of simple food.
And even beans--
there's a resurgence
of beans in New England, and
a lot of them can be dried.
And you can find those,
especially in Vermont.
There are those sources.
MATT JENNINGS: We're
drying beans actually
already at the restaurant.
We have kind of the rolling
racks with the sheet trays.
And as soon as those beans
start coming in the summer--
the shelling beans-- we
just start drying them.
CHRIS FISCHER: What varieties?
MATT JENNINGS: This last
year we did Rattlesnakes,
Devil's Tongues, and all sorts
of beautiful heirloom beans.
Cranberries.
CHRIS FISCHER: I'm
gonna grow these.
MATT JENNINGS: And as
soon as they come in,
we use some fresh,
and then we'll
put the rest on the drying
racks and put the fans on them.
Come September,
October, November,
we've got local beans.
It's great.
NICO MONDAY: But
it's a challenge.
MATT JENNINGS:
It's a lot of work.
NICO MONDAY: I won't pretend
that it's not a challenge.
CHRIS FISCHER: But it's
cost-effective too.
I mean, you really
save a lot of money,
especially when you
buy something in bulk.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned in
passing that a passionate chef
works 80, 90 hours a week.
And I want to know if
that's really what it takes.
And also, which nights
do you take off?
I heard Sunday nights
are not good nights
to go to restaurants?
CHRIS FISCHER: I think in any
profession-- you guys work
in a very competitive
field-- you either
need to work harder or smarter.
And I'm not that smart, so
I just always worked harder
than anyone else.
And so that to me would mean
yeah, over 100 hour weeks,
very, commonly.
NICO MONDAY: Opening a
restaurant, as all three of us
will probably
attest, is just that.
It is a test of your mettle.
And you don't sleep a
lot, and you hopefully
come out on the other
side six months later,
and you're still so
happy that you've
chosen to open a restaurant.
But yeah, I know.
It takes a lot.
It's like you said, it's a very
personal and passionate thing,
and you want to be
the one touching
every plate of food
that's going out,
which is really hard to do it.
But I think that
chefs try to do that,
especially in the beginning.
so
CHRIS FISCHER:
There's a lot to it.
I mean, everybody is
now an expert on food,
thanks to the internet
and to television.
And so there's pressure
coming into Boston.
You can't have missteps,
because that first bad review,
you know, that can
be the death of you.
I had a friend that opened
a restaurant in New York
recently, and he told me he
worked 120 days straight.
And I'm sure those
weren't short days.
And there's now a culture
of celebrity chefs.
And that's a great
thing in certain ways,
because it celebrates this
joyless-- in certain ways--
lifestyle.
But at the same
time, to be a chef
is so challenging on your body
and mentally and stress-wise
that a lot of people will
go to culinary school,
or they'll think they
want to be a cook,
and they'll work three
days in a kitchen,
and it's not what they
thought it was because
of how it's been perceived.
So it goes both ways.
NICO MONDAY: There's the
other side of that too.
The first time that
you get to experience
the pleasure of making
something that you think
is perfect and just
like, it's so tangible,
and then it just disappears.
For me, that's
when I think I knew
I wanted to become a cook was
the first time you know that I
actually remember thinking
of something, making it,
having it turn out, and
then just like it goes away.
And it goes away.
And you get to do that.
CHRIS FISCHER: It's spiritual.
And that's like
growing food too.
You've spent all this
time on the soil,
and you think about
it all winter.
My grandfather always
said that anticipation was
his favorite part of farming.
And I love that line.
I love that idea.
And it's true.
And you look at the soil, and
you see that little seedling,
and then it's a fava
sprout that comes up.
It's that high, and you
nibble off some of the leaves,
and they're like
taste like nothing.
It's just that nutty,
perfect thing on a salad.
And then you wait a
little bit longer,
and you get those fava beans.
And you've been
waiting for six weeks,
and then there's four
pods, and you get 15 beans.
And you eat them and
then they're gone.
And then you start over.
Again, it teaches
you impermanence,
and it's a beautiful thing.
Thank you for articulating that.
MATT JENNINGS: I'd say my answer
to that question would just
be that it takes everything
if you want to be good.
It's like anything else, right?
I'm sure there's programmers
and people of other ilk in here.
And you want to be the best,
it's the time you put in.
I still have
members of my family
that don't understand it.
My mom's like still to this day.
CHRIS FISCHER: Why
are you doing it?
MATT JENNINGS: Like, Mom, I've
been cooking for 25 years,
and I still get--
NICO MONDAY: When are you
gonna start your career?
MATT JENNINGS: Should be
with your family today.
It's like yeah, I know.
But it's worth it.
You have to love it, obviously,
and when you love it,
then good things come out of it.
And I think it's also about
training that next generation.
For me, it's so
much about training
that next generation
those same types of ideas
and fundamentals.
Nico and I-- neither of
us could be here today
if we didn't have
people that we trusted.
And so you eventually have to
also get to that point, right?
So there's a flip
side of it that you
have to get them to see things
the way that you see things.
And that's probably the most
challenging aspect, I think.
I think the hardest part of
our industry is people, right?
The food's one thing-- you can
teach a monkey, to a degree,
how to plate something.
But it's the emotion that--
NICO MONDAY: You can't
teach the sensibility.
MATT JENNINGS: You
can't teach sensibility.
NICO MONDAY: You can't
teach someone how to care.
MATT JENNINGS: Right, right.
How to care.
CHRIS FISCHER: Well,
and having a mentor,
and having-- like when you
made that first perfect piece
of fish, and you fed it to
your mentor, and they tasted it
and they said it was perfect.
Again, that's like the most
beautiful thing in the world.
And I was reading
about you a little bit,
and somebody was observing
you in the kitchen.
And there was a moment of calm,
and you looked at the kitchen
and you said, I love all of you.
I just want you to know that.
And again, I have
the same feeling.
That's part of the
camaraderie of a kitchen.
That's something that you
can't get anywhere else.
And so flipping on what I said
about the hardness of being
a cook and all that is
that you'll never find
a family like that,
especially if maybe you
have a broken
family, or you don't
have the most perfect
situation at home.
But you can't emulate
going to work.
At Babbo-- this is in
Manhattan, and this
was when we were doing 300
covers a night for dinner,
and we were a
three-star restaurant,
and there was all this pressure.
We had a line, and
there's five of us.
And before service, it's just
you're sharpening knives.
I just remember everybody
in there just sullen-faced,
duct-taping every
wound on your body.
Your hands, you have a headache.
You haven't even
started working.
And then you just go to
war, and then it's over.
And then you start
over and do over again.
MATT JENNINGS:
Food for me-- food
and cooking and running
a restaurant, I mean,
the whole thing is
very emotional for me.
I get really emotional.
And I get really emotional also
I think when I see the kids
and the folks who are working
for me get passionate about it.
Then I know that we're
succeeding on some level.
When they receive an
ingredient-- for them,
watching my growers, my farmer
show up to the back doors,
those people are rock stars.
Forget the chefs.
They don't care about me.
I mean, they care about
what I think, obviously,
but it's the farmers
and the growers
and the fishermen
and the producers
that they're just
like, oh my God.
Is Steve coming today?
What's he bringing?
He's bringing radishes?
And so that's when you
know, like OK, cool.
We're doing the right thing.
CHRIS FISCHER: And then when
they succeed, and they move on
from your restaurant, and they
go and they open their own.
Again, when you see
them have that success,
then you've done your
job very, very well.
MATT JENNINGS: Yup.
CHRIS FISCHER: Any
more questions?
NICO MONDAY: Cool.
MATT JENNINGS: There's a
really nice book over here.
CHRIS FISCHER: The
Beetlebung Farm Cookbook.
It's about a year of
growing, cooking, living
on Martha's Vineyard.
But I'm from the
Island, and my family's
been there for 350 years.
And it's more than just a year.
It was quite the process
to learn about that Island,
and about New England,
and about myself.
And so thank you
for your support.
Thank you for having us Google.
NICO MONDAY: Yeah.
Thank you for having us.
CHRIS FISCHER:
Thanks for the water.
MATT JENNINGS: Thanks, thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS FISCHER: And there's
chicharrones on your way out.